the gates of uh Paradise are open and
the gates of hell are closed does this
mean that we will be going to Paradise
if we die in this blessed month this
again is the same question of the same
Hadith same Hadith which ordred earlier
of M ahm Vol number two page number 230
Hadith number 7148 and it also appears
in chapter number 5 Hadith number 21106
again the same Hadith the prophet said
he told the people that the blessed
month of Ramadan is approaching and
Allah is ordering for you that you fast
in this
month and in this month the Gates of
Heaven will be open and the Gates of
Hell will be closed and the Devils will
be chained in this month is the night of
Kadar which is more blessed than a
thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the pleasures of the blessings in this
month is truly a deprived person here
again this is a common question question
that if the Gates of Heaven are open and
the gates of hell are closed then anyone
who dies but natur will go to Jenna
because the Gates of Hell closed and J
open